ZAK
ZAKARIA, HOST OF "FAREED ZAKARIA
GPS."
AS I ASK YOU EVERY SINGLE NIGHT,
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO THIS
BREAKING NEWS?
IT'S NOT FUNNY BUT IT'S
LAUGHABLE.
EVERY SINGLE TIME I HAVE YOU ON,
THERE IS SOME BREAKING NEWS.
THE PRESIDENT HAS DONE SOMETHING
OUTRAGEOUS.
AND HERE WE ARE REACTING TO IT.
>> WELL, IN THIS CASE, IT SEEMS
TO ME IT'S, YOU KNOW, YOU ALMOST
HAVE TO HOPE FOR INCOMPETENCE
BECAUSE THE ALTERNATIVE IS SO
DARK.
AND SO LET'S GO WITH THE
INCOMPETENCE THEORY.
>> DO YOU THINK HE'S
INCOMPETENT?
>> I CERTAINLY THINK THAT HE
DOES NOT SEEM TO EITHER
UNDERSTAND OR CARE ABOUT THE
STRUCTURES AND PROCESSES OF HIGH
GOVERNMENT OFFICE.
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE CASES
WHERE, AGAIN, THE FACT THAT YOU
RAN A PRETTY SUCCESSFUL REAL
ESTATE FRANCHISING OPERATION IN
NEW YORK CITY DOES NOT REALLY
TRANSLATE INTO RUNNING THE
UNITED STATES BECAUSE THIS IS A
MATTER OF KIND OF VERY, VERY
SENSITIVE INTELLIGENCE.
HOW YOU SHARE IT, WHO YOU SHARE
IT WITH AND YOU NEED TO
UNDERSTAND YOUR GOVERNMENT
SPENDS -- WE SPENT $70 BILLION
ON INTELLIGENCE.
OTHER COUNTRIES SPEND BILLIONS
AND BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
THESE ARE THE CROWN JEWELS OF
THESE, AND TO PUT THEM ALL, YOU
KNOW, TO EXPOSE ALL OF THAT
WITHOUT REALLY HAVING THOUGHT IT
THROUGH SEEMS INCREDIBLY
CARELESS.
IT SUGGESTS A KIND OF LACK OF
RESPECT FOR YOUR ALLIES.
SO, THAT'S THE BENIGN
INTERPRETATION.
THE LESS BENIGN INTERPRETATION
IS THAT THIS WAS SOME KIND OF,
YOU KNOW, THAT THIS WAS PROVIDED
TO THE RUSSIANS IN A WAY THAT
WAS -- YOU KNOW, HE WAS HELPING
THE RUSSIANS --
CAUSED GENERAL FLYNN TO BE
FIRED.
>> SO THE CENTRAL PUZZLE OF
TRUMP'S WORLD VIEW AND FOREIGN
POLICY FROM THE START OF THE
CAMPAIGN TO NOW HAS BEEN VERY
SIMPLE, WHY IS HE SO NICE TO THE
RUSSIANS, RIGHT?
THIS IS A GUY AS I'VE SAID TO
YOU, WHEN HE STARTED HIS FOREIGN
POLICY, HIS WHOLE POINT WAS
EVERYBODY IN THE WORLD SCREWS
THE AMERICANS.
WE GET -- WE ALWAYS LOSE, THEY
ALWAYS WIN, I'M GOING TO GET
TOUGH ON THE REST OF THE WORLD.
HE FELT THAT WAY ABOUT THE
JAPANESE SINCE THE 198 Os, HE'S
FE
FELT THAT WAY ABOUT NATO ALLIES
SINCE THE 1980s.
HE'S FELTS THAT WAY ABOUT
BRITAIN, FRANCE, GERMANY.
>> CHINA.
>> EXCEPT THE RUSSIANS.
SO STTHAT WAS HIS FEELING DURIN
THE CAMPAIGN AND SO EVEN TODAY
WHAT WE DISCOVER IS HE SPILLS
THE BEANS NOT TO THE BRITS, NOT
TO THE GERMANS --
>> BUT TO THE RUSSIANS.
>> -- NOT TO THE FRENCH, BUT TO
THE RUSSIANS.
>> SO KISLYAK, LET ME GET
BACK -- AGAIN, HE'S AT THE
CENTER OF A LOT OF THIS AND
APPARENTLY ACCORDING TO THE
REPORTING HE'S IN THERE SORT OF
BOASTING ABOUT THIS INFORMATION
AND HE THINKS THAT, I GET THE
BEST INTELLIGENCE, WHAT HAVE
YOU.
DOES HE UNDERSTAND THAT KISLYAK
AND THE RUSSIANS MAY BE PLAYING
HIM IN THE OVAL OFFICE?
DOES HE NOT UNDERSTAND THIS?
IS HIS EGO THAT BIG OR HE'S NOT
THAT SELF-AWARE THAT HE MAY NOT
REALIZE HE'S GETTING PLAYED,
HIMSELF?
>> WHEN I LOOK AT HOW OTHER
COUNTRIES ARE NOW HANDLING
TRUMP, WHAT I'M STRUCK BY IS
SHEER YOU HAVE VLADIMIR PUTIN
WHO HAS ESSENTIALLY BEEN RUNNING
RUSSIA FOR 15 YEARS.
OPERATING THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF
INTERNATIONAL POLITICIAS.
LOOK AT XI JINPING, A SEASONED
POLITICAL OPERATOR FOR 30 YEARS.
WHAT DOES HE DO WITH TRUMP?
TRUMP TRIES TO DO THE TAIWAN
PLAY.
HE SHUTS IT DOWN COMPLETELY.
THEN HE REWARDS THE TRUMP
ORGANIZATION, BIZARRELY, WITH 35
TRADEMARKS THEY'VE BEEN TRYING
TO GET FOR YEARS AND YEARS.
HE REWARDS IVANKA TRUMP WITH
TRADEMARKS.
SO THESE GUYS ARE PLAYING AT A
VERY HIGH LEVEL OF
SOPHISTICATION.
>> THEY LEARNED THAT --
>> CARROTS AND STICKS.
>> MR. TRUMP, YOU'RE THE BEST,
YOU'RE THE SMARTEST, WHATEVER,
THAT HE WILL --
>> RIGHT.
I JUST WONDER, ARE WE -- YOU
KNOW, ONE OF THE THINGS TRUMP
KEPT SAYING IS YOU'RE GOING DO
GET TIRED OF WINNING ONCE I'M
PRESIDENT.
>> WHEN DOES THE WINNING START?
>>